it's great to welcome back to the
program tom hartman who's the host of
the thom hartmann program and also
author of the new book the hidden
history of monopolies how big business
destroyed the american dream tom as
always great to see you
thank you david uh the book has a
forward by ralph nader too which is
uh the forward is almost worth the cost
of the book it's amazing
i i've actually spoken to ralph nader
about about this issue
and um many people i mean maybe a good
place to start
is i don't know that everybody
understands how far back
monopolies and monopolistic behavior by
firms in the united states goes you talk
about it dating all the way back to the
revolution which may surprise some
people
yeah the boston tea party was a revolt
against a monopolistic company the east
india company was the largest
uh monopoly in the world at the time
uh they had monopolized tea in the
united states along with a lot of other
things
it was illegal to manufacture fine
clothing in the united states for
example certain types of weaponry
certain certain types of furniture they
all had to be manufactured in england
and imported
by the east india company and so when
the
depression or recession of 1770 hit
the the east india company petitioned
the british government
for basically some cash they were
stretched
and the british government uh said uh
we'll give you a refund on millions of
dollars worth of tea
that you've got in today's dollars that
you have in in
inventory because they back then they
paid tax when they received the t
from india not when they sold it and uh
so the east india company got this huge
multi-million dollar
tax rebate that allowed them to drop
their price on t
into the united states and compete with
the with the american smugglers
which made the american people just
furious
and uh thus the tea party in our our
nation was
birthed in a revolt against corporate
monopoly
when we think about the different times
in american history
where there's been more of a focus on
trust busting
and going after monopolies are there
certain industries that have regularly
sort of skirted the scrutiny that maybe
they deserve
well there are some industries that have
been better at it than others and that
it tends to
have to do with how much political power
they have which is usually a consequence
of either financial power or
essential industry you know banks or
pharmaceutical companies for example
but you know the the simple reality is
that um
you know just like cancer in the body is
when one cell decides i'm going to take
over the entire body and starts
growing and growing and growing without
limit and
redirecting all the resources of the
body to itself until it ultimately kills
the body
monopoly is cancer within capitalism
and our bodies have an immune system
that you know we're constantly every day
where
our bodies are producing cancerous cells
and our immune system is gobbling them
up this is just a normal part
of uh you know biology well similarly
you know we developed an immune system
and capitalism is really in its modern
form only about 300 years old
and back in the 1880s here in the united
states we developed an immune system
following on what had been done in
europe just before um to that cancer of
monopoly which was the sherman antitrust
act and then later
in the 1930s the clayton antitrust act
and then the 1956
antitrust act or anti-monopoly law
and uh you know it worked it worked
fairly well
uh but the problem was in 1982 in 1983
ronald reagan ordered the justice
department the sec and the commerce
department to stop enforcing those laws
and that led to this explosion of
consolidation the mergers and
acquisition mania
those people old enough to remember it
uh it was a wild time michael milken and
you know greed is good and all this
stuff
and all these companies being jammed
together and the workers being fired the
pension puns
funds being stolen most people remember
the airlines twday
and eastern and you know they got gutted
this way but it happened in
every sector of american business and
now here 40 years later
there is not literally not one single
industrial sector or major uh sector
of the american economy left that is not
dominated by three to five
large companies that control sixty to
eighty percent of the total revenue
and operate as functionally as a
monopoly
technically you'd call it an oligopoly
and as a result of this the average
american family is paying about five
thousand dollars a year more
for the goods and services that they buy
than they would if we didn't have a
monopoly
internet service for example in europe
is typically 25 to 30 dollars a month
for you know one gigabyte up and down
here in the united states you paid two
to three times that
because we've got just a you know a
handful of internet service providers
now
um you know yeah i wanted to ask about
the 5000 because i think that that's
interesting so
when when you you write in the book that
the the monopoly in the united states
essentially
ex expands or increases the amount that
the average
family spends on a yearly basis by five
thousand dollars and what you're talking
about there would be
well on internet it might be an
additional 60
a month times 12 there you've got 720.
what are what are the other areas where
cell phone services pharmaceuticals
um you know basically everything except
cheap junk from
china and and uh and and what the cheap
junk from china has
succeeded in doing is running out of
business
literally thousands of american american
companies uh you know since the 1980s
we've been losing
um you know on average 7 800 factories a
year
in some cases thousands of factories a
year we were up to losing 5 000
factories a year uh you know after the
city after signing nafta
and and each one of those factories
represents hundreds to thousands in some
cases even tens of thousands of jobs
you know according to the commerce
department according to our official
statistics
we've lost millions of jobs to to uh to
this kind of
monopolistic behavior only in this case
the monopoly is
another country you know and and you
know a little help from walmart and
their friends
so uh you know it's right across the
board david
how has the um when you look at the lack
of appetite
to really deal with this in the united
states dating back for some time you
talked about ronald reagan you've talked
about it in the 18th century
is it as simple as a sort of version
of regulatory capture and a calculation
from those empowered that this is just
not
where their regulatory uh oversight is
um an area that they want to focus or is
is there more to it than that well by
and large that's how it's played out
but they're they're as usual the story
is is a little more complicated and a
little
seemier and weirder um you know back in
the 1960s
uh milton friedman was teaching at the
university of chicago and
or you know was at the university of
chicago and one of his uh
students robert bork uh got all
uh inflamed about this idea all you know
hair on fire about this idea that he had
learned from milton friedman that
that we shouldn't traditionally america
had viewed a corporation as having
multiple constituencies a corporation
had a responsibility to the community in
which it operated
to not mistreat that community or
pollute it to its employees to pay them
well and
and you know serve them to its customers
to make sure its customers weren't you
know ripped off or burned
um to the institution of the corporation
itself
and to its shareholders and senior
management
and bork came along and said all that is
nonsense you guys have complicated this
way too much it's really simple if
consumers pay less
then it's not a monopoly and uh you know
people thought he was a crackpot in the
sixties but he persisted he wrote a book
about it he testified to congress he
engaged a multi-year major lobbying
campaign
and by the time reagan tried to put him
on the supreme court
and we discovered that he not only was a
crackpot but also a racist and a
homophobe
um you know by that time the supreme
court in the 1970s in a case called gte
sylvania
had concluded that bork was right and
that you know and that reagan was right
and that we're going to set all this
stuff aside and we're only going to
enforce the anti-monopoly laws based on
whether prices are going up for
consumers
of course since then prices have gone up
on consumers tremendously
but you know basically the the
enforcement was killed
so we're back right now where we were in
1900 you know and and you know we're
faced with a situation like the one that
teddy roosevelt and william howard taft
took on
correct me if i'm wrong but it seems
that that the coronavirus pandemic has
really accelerated the consolidation
of market share um for the players that
were already some of the biggest players
i mean we're seeing with amazon
walmart places that immediately uh
scaled up
uh particularly those that are that that
use if they're using these third-party
sprinter vans to deliver stuff that is a
sign if you work
backwards that those are the the the
players
that are increasing market share and i
just don't know like
we would need a total rethink of the
economy to prevent that from naturally
happening in a situation like the one we
find ourselves in right i mean if
it from my perspective what the virus
exposed was
that a bunch of the economy is
significantly more
fragile than what we like to believe on
a day-to-day basis and as soon as that
became clear
those that were positioned to seize on
the opportunity have done so
yeah i mean the reason why so many aids
patients died of karposis or komak a
cancer
is because their immune system has been
shut down and you know so cancer could
grow in the body
um the reason why monopoly has now
seized america
and our economy has been run by a couple
hundred billionaires
is because is because ronald reagan
stripped away our immune system
he he gave us the the business
equivalent of aids
and and you know our country is
suffering terribly for it
uh we've got to bring back that immune
system we've got to be pushing back
against the cancer of monopoly
so what's the infrastructure that you
think needs needs to be put in place is
it as simple as just
enforcing what is on the books or do we
actually need
a new framework in which we are going to
approach this issue
well as is so often the case with with
um
you know pro structural problems in
modern america so much of this goes back
to the supreme court
uh you know my last book was all about
that and and actually the book before
last
and uh you know between the court in 78
76 and 78 giving billionaires and
corporations the right to own
politicians and entire political parties
and calling it free speech
um combined with the gte sylvania case
where the court
re you know re-understood explicit
you know monopoly laws the anti-monopoly
laws explicitly talk about these
multiple constituencies and
how you determine you know everything
and the court just said oh you know
we're going to ignore all that and go
with robert bork
um you know we need legislation that
includes a court stripping provision
which i write about my supreme court
book that overturns
that supreme court decision and the ones
that have followed
and that re-regulates american business
in a way that prevents it from being
cancerous
if you uh have the idea that
if joe biden wins in november and puts
somebody like elizabeth warren who has
spoken about the issue of monopoly
as secretary of commerce for example or
or in some regulatory role
is it naive to think that that alone
might make a difference like is this
just way bigger than that
i think that america is poised on the
edge of the possibility
of a of a of another great renewal
um it seems like roughly every 80 years
we go through a crisis
and then as we come out of the crisis on
the back end weeks we
a renewal explosion uh you had the
crisis of 1770 it led to the american
revolution you had the crisis of the
civil war and the oligarchy in the south
and that led to the civil war but also
led to all the
the changes the post-civil war changes
very positive changes
um you had the the great crash of 1929
the republican great depression
that led to the new deal and all those
changes um you know
a smaller crisis the assassination of
jack kennedy led
to medicare medicaid civil rights act
voting rights act etc
and i think that the crisis of the trump
presidency in this giant
drifter on job the billionaires have
been running on us
um has set the stage for a renewal the
question is
number one can we get a democrat elected
now or has trump so corrupted americans
uh america's electoral systems that that
he's gonna you know turn us into
uh you know uh trumpistan um and number
two
if we do get a democratic administration
whether they will have the
the the vision and the boldness to go
ahead
if if elizabeth warren is at the helm or
is you know has a substantial say in it
wherever that may be and however it may
play out
i'm very enthusiastic and very excited
and very hopeful
if she gets marginalized and it becomes
you know basically a reinvention of the
clinton and obama presidencies that were
deeply in the pockets of large
corporations
then um you know i'm i'm concerned
but that's a that's a debate and a
discussion we can have once we
once we put our uh you know our house is
on fire right now we get the
fire out yeah first you put the fire out
before you figure out how to do
how to fix what what what's been burned
let's go
discuss how to paint the rooms yeah
exactly yeah right yeah the
searching for that uh analogy and you
you found it
last last thing on this um there's an
entire political movement in the united
states which heavily fetishizes the idea
of
eliminating regulation which is
hampering and restricting business
etc etc how much of this is going to be
an uphill battle until that starts to be
dealt with as well
well this is where we've got a big job
to do in educating the american people
because the simple fact of the matter is
that
there is only one force on earth
that can constrain or restrain a
billion-dollar corporation when it wants
to pollute the water
put poison in the air kill people with
crappy products
oppress workers and and rip off their
employees
there's only literally one power on
earth that could fight back against that
and that's government
and you know the the right-wing
billionaires you know the koch brothers
and their buddies
back in the day knew that they
understood that and when their boy
ronald reagan got elected they you know
in his first inaugural address
for you know minutes after he was sworn
into office his first speech he said
government is not the solution to your
problem government
is the problem he laid the the he set
the table
for this destruction of america that's
been going on for 40 years
and and you know it is some serious
repair work that needs to be done but i
think if enough people
wake up and realize how badly we have
been harmed by this
bizarre small government ideology
that was only promoted over these 40
years by people who simply wanted to be
able to pollute and poison and rip off
with impunity then i think that there's
some considerable hope
the book is the hidden history of
monopolies how big
business destroyed the american dream
we've been speaking with the book's
author tom hartman
tom it's always so good to talk to you
thank you david it's always an honor and
a pleasure to be on your program